there isn't some definitive proof that  everyone is going to believe that like  oh well here's the proof of God you have  to suspend judgment a little bit right  you have to believe and I do think  psyched dogs help me do that because  they showed me things I couldn't see  what do you think about that I think all  of us need to get out of Our Own Way in  some way but it's like for example when  people go to prison right like and then  they find out in prison which happens to  a lot of people who are being homeless  so these sorts of things like God can  use these um different kind of  situations in order to point us to  himself I think that like the Bible  tells us to be so reminded so whatever  that entails but I don't I wouldn't say  that you should do psychedelics I think  that in this aspect God used it for good  you know he tons of all things around  for good for those